Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Merci beaucoup. Bonjour à tous.
Il me revient d’ouvrir la voie,
la voie avec un E et la voix avec un X,
à cette série de conférences
qui s’annoncent fascinantes.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous parler
de mes travaux de recherche en éthologie
et plus particulièrement de mes travaux
sur la communication vocale
chez les mammifères.
Le but de ma présentation,
c’est de vous convaincre
qu’étudier le comportement animal
ne nous renseigne pas seulement
sur le comportement des animaux,
mais aussi ça nous permet
de mieux comprendre
les origines et les fondements
de notre propre comportement,
du comportement humain.
Plus particulièrement aujourd’hui,
je vais vous proposer l’hypothèse
que la sélection sexuelle
a favorisé l’évolution de la complexité
et de la diversité vocale
chez les mammifères
et, par cela, a façonné, a ouvert la voie
pour l’évolution de la parole humaine.
Pour commencer, je vous propose
de faire un tour du monde,
un tour des cris de rut
des cervidés polygynes.
Polygyne, qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ce sont les espèces de cerfs
chez lesquelles le mâle s’accouple
avec plusieurs femelles.
Chez ces animaux, ça a créé une différence
entre les mâles et les femelles
dans le sens où les mâles vont entrer
en compétition pour l’accès aux femelles
et les femelles vont choisir
les mâles de meilleure qualité.
Et ça, ça a un effet sur le comportement
qui est assez sidérant.
Je vais commencer par vous présenter
le brame du cerf élaphe, du cerf rouge.
(Brame de cerf)
C’est ce que vous entendrez
si on vous propose d’aller écouter le cerf
au moment du rut, à l’automne,
dans les forêts françaises.
On va passer au cerf espagnol,
au cerf ibérique,
qui, lui, est un peu plus chantant.
(Brame de cerf ibérique)
Et maintenant, on va passer
au cerf de Corse,
qui est assez surprenant
parce qu’il a une taille assez petite,
mais malgré ça, il a une voix
très grave et très gutturale
qui donne un peu une idée du fait
qu’il exagère déjà sa taille corporelle.
(Brame de cerf corse)
On va passer au daim de Mésopotamie,
qui est en fait assez courant,
assez commun en France.
Vous verrez que chez cette espèce,
c’est vraiment très guttural,
pas très beau.
Ça s’appelle ‘roar’ en anglais,
‘belch’ ; c’est vraiment un rot.
(Brame de daim)
Ensuite, on va aller jusqu’en Inde
où il y a le barasinga.
Ce cerf émet un cri qui ressemble un peu
à une ambulance ou à une tyrolienne.
(Brame de barasinga)
On va faire un détour par la Chine.
(Brame de cerf du père David)
Ça, c’était le cerf du père David,
auquel je ne dois pas le nom.
On va ensuite aller faire un tour
auprès du cerf de Taïwan.
(Brame de cerf de Taïwan)
Là, ça commence à devenir étrange.
Le cerf de Timor.
(Brame de cerf de Timor)
De plus en plus surprenant
le sika du Japon.
(Brame de sika)
Vous avouerez que si vous entendez
ça au coin d’un bois la nuit,
vous ne serez pas forcément rassurés.
On va traverser le détroit de Béring
pour arriver en Amérique du Nord.
Là, on a le cri du wapiti.
(Brame de wapiti)
Il est assez intéressant
car il est polyphonique.
L’animal produit avec ses cordes vocales
un son, un brame de cerf normal
et en même temps produit un sifflement
dans ses cavités nasales.
Vous entendez les deux.
Ça lui permet de faire le gros,
en produisant en même temps un sifflement
qui s’entend sur de très grandes distances
et donc permet aux femelles
de repérer le mâle.
Toute cette diversité,
comme je l’ai expliqué,
elle vient du fait que, chez ces animaux,
le mâle ne participe pas
à l’élevage de jeunes
et donc augmente son succès reproducteur
en essayant de copuler
avec un maximum de femelles.
Et ça, ça crée donc un dimorphisme sexuel,
un dimorphisme comportemental,
où ce sont les mâles
qui vocalisent exclusivement.
La biche ne brame pas au clair de lune,
contrairement à ce que suggère le poète.
Les mâles produisent ces cris.
Une des informations les plus importantes
dans leurs vocalisations,
c’est l’expression
de la taille corporelle,
mais pas seulement l’expression, aussi
l’exagération de leur taille corporelle.
Il ne suffit pas de dire « Je suis gros »,
il faut vraiment essayer de paraître
le plus gros possible,
le plus fort possible.
Pour étudier ces sons,
il faut faire appel à une théorie
de la production de la voix,
la théorie « Source Filtre
de la production de la voix ».
Selon cette théorie,
quand on parle ou quand un animal
produit une vocalisation,
la production du son
se fait en deux étapes.
La première étape,
c’est lorsque les cordes vocales
entrent en vibration
lorsqu’on expulse l’air des poumons,
cette vibration va avoir
une fréquence de vibration,
la fréquence fondamentale,
qui est à l’origine du pitch de la voix.
C’est-à-dire que si mes cordes vocales
vibrent assez lentement,
j’ai un pitch bas.
Par contre, si elles vibrent plus vite,
j’ai un pitch beaucoup plus élevé.
Au niveau des cordes vocales,
on a un signal source
(Brame de cerf)
qui n’est pas très joli,
qui heureusement est ensuite filtré
dans les cavités supra-laryngées
de l’animal,
c’est-à-dire la bouche, la cavité nasale
et le pharynx, pour les animaux
qui ont un pharynx.
Cet effet de filtrage ajoute au signal
le timbre qui est caractéristique
de la voix de l’animal.
(Brame de cerf)
Voici le signal résultant.
Je vous explique ça,
car pour ce qui est de l’encodage,
l’exagération, de la taille,
on a deux moyens, dans les signaux,
les animaux ont deux moyens
pour encoder cette information.
Le premier : plus un animal est gros,
plus ses cordes vocales sont longues,
plus le pitch de sa voix va être bas.
Là, je vais vous passer
deux brames de cerf.
Un à pitch élevé, petit animal ;
un à pitch bas, gros animal.
(Brame de cerf - pitch élevé)
(Brame de cerf - pitch bas)
Vous voyez la différence ?
Vous êtes d’accord que le premier
paraît plus petit que le second ?
Mais ce n’est pas le seul paramètre
que l’animal va modifier.
Il peut aussi modifier
les fréquences de résonance,
c’est-à-dire que
plus le tractus vocal est long,
plus le tube de résonance est long,
plus le timbre va être bas.
(Brame de cerf)
Là, j’ai passé un animal
avec un petit tractus vocal,
puis un animal avec un long.
Là aussi, vous êtes d’accord
que le deuxième paraît plus grand.
Ce sont deux dimensions de la voix
sur lesquelles jouer
pour véhiculer et exagérer
la taille vocale.
Dans le règne animal,
il y a tout un tas d’exagérateurs.
On sort des cervidés.
Je vais vous passer une vidéo
filmée en Bolivie de singes hurleurs.
Vous allez voir que l’animal
va produire une vocalisation
qui vraiment a la fonction d'exagérer.
C’est un singe qui n’est pas très gros ;
écoutez le son de sa vocalisation.
(Cris de singe hurleur)
Ce singe n’est pas très gros, mais produit
des sons qui sont beaucoup plus graves
que ce à quoi on s’attend
pour sa taille corporelle.
Il fait ça grâce à un larynx
qui est disproportionné
et un sac hyoïdien aussi
qui est disproportionné.
Ils lui permettent donc d’avoir
des cordes vocales beaucoup plus longues
que ce à quoi on s’attendrait.
Vous voyez aussi, au niveau
de la posture de la bouche,
qu’il augmente la taille de son résonateur
pour abaisser ses fréquences de résonance.
On va passer à un autre animal, le koala,
qui, lui, vraiment est tout petit -
il pèse quelques kilos -
et qui a aussi la capacité d’émettre
des sons qui sont extrêmement graves.
En fait, le pitch du koala est comparable
au pitch du cri de l’éléphant.
(Grognements de koala)
Oui, c’est un petit peu dégoûtant.
Ce qu’il se passe chez le koala,
c’est qu’il a évolué
un deuxième jeu de cordes vocales.
Il n’utilise pas ses cordes vocales.
Quand un koala les utilise,
le son qui sort, ça fait un petit « i ».
Ce n’est pas un son grave,
pas du tout le son qu’on vient d’entendre.
Par contre, le koala utilise
son voile de palais, le velum,
sur lequel il a évolué des cordes vocales
qui ont exactement
le même type de structure
que les cordes vocales dans le larynx
qui lui permettent donc,
comme quand on ronfle,
de produire un son
qui est très très grave.
On va revenir chez les cervidés,
cette fois avec le daim.
(Vocalises de daim)
Si vous observez l’animal
pendant qu’il vocalise, pendant le rut,
vous voyez qu’il a une pomme d’Adam,
un peu comme chez l’homme, chez l’humain.
Cette pomme d’Adam
est assez basse dans le cou,
mais en plus quand il vocalise,
il l’abaisse en direction du sternum.
Ça lui permet d’étirer son tractus vocal
et d’abaisser ses fréquences de résonance
pour paraître plus gros qu’il ne l’est.
On peut le revoir dans cette vidéo.
Vous avez un spectrogramme,
vous voyez les fréquences
de résonance qui s’abaissent
(Brame de daim)
en synchronie
avec les mouvements du larynx.
Ce comportement,
assez exceptionnel chez les mammifères,
est rendu possible
grâce à des adaptations.
Vous voyez ici un CT scan,
une reconstitution 3D
de l’appareil vocal du daim.
Le larynx est en position basse.
Normalement, chez le mouton, par exemple,
le larynx serait positionné ici.
Là, il est en position basse
et pendant la vocalisation,
le larynx est abaissé
de manière à étirer le tractus vocal,
à allonger le tube de résonance
et à produire des résonances
beaucoup plus graves
que prévu par la taille de l'animal.
Là, on voit donc en coupe sagittale
l’effet de l’abaissement du larynx
sur les voies aériennes.
Vous voyez donc que ce tube s’allonge
effectivement par l’abaissement du larynx.
Pourquoi je vous parle de ça ?
En fait, il y a
un parallèle très intéressant
entre ces animaux et l’humain.
Parce que chez l’homme,
chez le mâle uniquement, adulte,
on a aussi une pomme d’Adam
qui, au repos, est en position basse
et qui est aussi protubérante.
Au moment de la puberté,
sous l’effet de la testostérone,
la taille du larynx va croître,
ce qui va donner
des cordes vocales plus graves
et donc faire baisser
le pitch de notre voix.
Le larynx va aussi descendre un peu,
ce qui va allonger
la longueur de notre tractus.
Longtemps, on a cru
que la position du larynx chez l’homme,
dans le cou, assez basse,
avait évolué pour permettre la parole.
Or, on a bien vu que cette position,
elle est présente chez le daim,
qui ne dit rien d’autre que :
« Je suis gros. Je veux me reproduire. »
On sait aussi que, à l’adolescence,
lorsque le larynx descend
chez l’adolescent humain,
ça n’augmente pas
les capacités verbales des garçons,
qui sont généralement plutôt en retard
sur les filles dans ce domaine-là.
Je veux juste vous montrer…
On va partir de la voix
d'une femme adulte.
(Voix de femme)
I can’t chase a rabbit down the path.
On va abaisser les résonances de 20%,
allonger le tractus vocal.
(Voix plus grave)
I can’t chase a rabbit down the path.
On a une voix un peu bizarre : un pitch
de femme dans un appareil vocal d’homme.
Ensuite, par contre, si on raccourcit…
Si on réduit le pitch
de 100 Hz, on obtient -
(Voix d’homme)
I can’t chase a rabbit down the path.
une voix d’homme.
Vous voyez les contributions
à la fois du pitch et des résonances
à la différence entre la voix de l’homme
et la voix de la femme.
Ce qui est intéressant, c’est de voir
que la sélection sexuelle chez l’homme
aussi a ouvert l’espace acoustique,
a ouvert l’espace sonore,
et nous amène à des capacités vocales
avec une bimodalité où on a la voix
de la femme, la voix de l’homme
et la possibilité de moduler notre voix
pour paraître plus féminin, plus masculin,
plus dominant, plus dominé, etc.
Les rois de la modulation de la voix
pour exprimer leur genre,
ce sont les enfants.
Avant la puberté,
les petits garçons, les petites filles
ont exactement la même taille corporelle,
le même appareil vocal.
Ils devraient avoir exactement
la même voix.
Or, si je vous passe
la voix d’un petit garçon :
(Voix de garçon)
Look at the rule of the spooky castle
et la voix d’une petite fille
du même âge :
(Voix de fille)
Look at the rule of the spooky castle
Vous n’avez pas de difficulté
à différencier, à reconnaître
que le premier est un garçon,
que le second est une fille.
La raison pour laquelle
vous entendez cette différence,
c’est que, en fait, les enfants
jouent leur genre lorsqu’ils parlent.
Ils imitent les différences
qu’ils entendent
dans les voix des adultes, qui, elles,
sont dues à des différences anatomiques,
et qu’ils imitent aussi les différences
qui sont jouées par leurs camarades.
Lorsqu’un petit garçon parle,
il a tendance à parler avec les lèvres
un peu plus en avant,
le larynx un peu plus descendu,
alors que les filles ont tendance
à parler avec un sourire.
La seule différence
dans la voix des enfants est liée
à cette modulation comportementale
de la longueur du tractus vocal.
Quand on demande à un garçon de parler
comme une fille, il se met à sourire,
et à une fille de parler comme un garçon,
elle arrondit ses lèvres et prend
un air un petit peu plus sérieux.
Alors…
Ça, c’est un aspect intéressant.
Si pour paraître femme,
on doit raccourcir son tractus vocal,
ça veut dire aussi dire
qu’il faut qu’on sourie.
Les primates sont assez exceptionnels
dans le royaume animal,
dans le sens où ce sont
les seules espèces, y compris nous,
qui montrons nos dents
dans une situation d’apaisement.
Généralement, montrer les dents,
ça signifie l’intention d’attaquer.
Or, chez les primates,
on raccourcit notre tractus vocal,
probablement parce qu’au départ,
cette expression faciale était associée
à un son qui signifiait :
« Je suis petit, je suis plus femelle,
je suis plus jeune,
je suis moins agressif. »
Au cours de l’évolution,
il est possible que le sourire,
l’expression faciale,
soit devenue indépendante
de la production de son.
Pour en revenir à cette ouverture
de l’espace vocal,
avec un pôle aigu femelle
et un pôle grave mâle,
on a donc dans la voix la possibilité
de moduler notre voix
pour paraître plus féminin,
si on est une femme,
d’augmenter le pitch de la voix
pour paraître plus sexy, pour paraître
plus aimable, plus inoffensive,
plus maternelle, plus conciliante,
plus dominée, etc.
Et en contrepartie,
lorsqu’on est un homme,
abaisser le pitch de la voix, ça permet
de paraître plus compétent, plus masculin,
un meilleur leader, plus dangereux,
plus dominant, plus agressif, etc.
Ça pose un petit problème pour les femmes
qui n’existe pas chez l’homme :
pour une femme, pour être plus sexy,
il faut augmenter le pitch de la voix.
Par contre, quand on augmente le pitch,
on paraît moins compétent,
moins sûr de soi, etc.
Donc là, il y a un trade-off, un compromis
qui est un petit peu compliqué,
dont il faut peut-être un peu tenir compte
quand on a des réunions
avec des collègues femmes.
Je vous remercie pour votre attention.
J’espère vous avoir convaincu
qu’étudier le comportement animal,
ça nous permet de mieux comprendre
le comportement humain
et aussi d’avoir des angles d’approche
sur les mécanismes
de nos comportements de tous les jours
auxquels on ne penserait pas
si on se focalisait
uniquement sur l’humain.
Je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)